Speaker 1: I want to look with you at some
record setting clips of a new Donald Trump
interview Donald Trump was interviewed and to
call it an interview is kind of weird because
it was just a fluff piece. Ronna McDaniel,
the RNC chair who I guess now has a podcast
she interviewed Donald Trump and Donald
Trump. I'm going to play a clip for you in
which I believe in 12 seconds, he tells
Four Lies. It's it's record setting,
quite literally. But just to give you
a sense of this bizarre interview,
here is Ronna McDaniel talking about how great
Trump has been to women. I know, guys. I know.
Speaker 3: Thank you for what you're
doing. Thank you for being out there.
I just have two fun things I want to say to you.
Speaker 1: There's going to be fun, guys.
We're about to have fun and
Speaker 3: you're such a
wonderful person. You've been so great to
women. Thank you for what you're doing.
Speaker 1: Trump's been accused of harassment
through assault of 46 women by 46 women,
and she says, You just been so fantastic for
women. Now, here's the clip. This is a 17
second clip. Ronna McDaniel speaks for five
seconds, so Trump only speaks for 12 seconds,
and he tells four lies. See
if you can spot him. OK,
here's. It'll be like a game show
Speaker 3: there, and you saved hundreds
of thousands, if not millions of lives with
Speaker 4: that. When you know, we had in 1917,
100 million people died, I think we
would have had the same thing. So
we did something that was incredible. We did it in
less than nine months and it was supposed to take
anywhere from five to 12 years there.
Speaker 5: And you got
Speaker 1: so did you spot the four lies or
misstatements there? First, he only spoke 12
seconds more like 11, but the math is easier if we
say 12. He said that there was a pandemic in 1917,
there wasn't. It was in 1918. He keeps telling
that lie. We don't know why he's sticking with it.
Number two, he says that if it weren't for the
vaccines he developed, 100 million people would
have died of COVID. There is no serious estimate
that suggests that number three. He says he's
the one who got the vaccines done. That's also
untrue. All he did was agree to pre-purchase some
vaccines, which any American president would have
done in this situation. And number four, he says
if it were not for him, it would have taken five
to 12 years to develop the vaccine. That's not
true with the vaccine that you build from scratch.
That was historically the case. M RNA technology
has been in development for decades, and the
whole point of RNA technology is you can much more
quickly sequence a virus and develop a vaccine in
about a year, which is exactly what happened for
lies in 12 seconds. Unbelievable. Couple other
clips from this interview. Here is Trump saying
stopping Nord Stream was the worst
thing to ever happen to Russia.
History buffs will know that's not true.
Speaker 4: There was never anybody tougher
on Russia than I was. Now that's a lie also, and I
would say that Putin would if he was being honest,
he would say that the sanctions I put on, I was
the one that ended Nord Stream. Exactly. There
was never anybody even close. I mean, Nord Stream
two them Nord Stream two was the biggest thing.
Nobody ever even heard of it until I came along
and complained. And then I shut it down. And there
was never anything so big that happened to Russia
shutting down Nord Stream two and then now Russia.
Speaker 1: You know, the Soviet Union lost
27 million people during World War Two,
and then when the USSR collapsed, one of the just
absolute and total economic disaster. I think
it's a bit exaggerated to say Nord Stream two was
the worst and biggest thing that happened there.
And then lastly, Trump says the following about
how President Xi reacted to Biden pulling out
of Afghanistan.
Speaker 4:
I think that's actually a big reason why the
problem you have with Ukraine, I think when Putin
and with Xi and when Kim Jong UN and when the
Iranians are watching that, the Iranian leaders,
I think they saw what happened in
Afghanistan, and I think that gave them
a new sense of power and dignity.
Speaker 1: What is he even? It's a word salad.
It's a word salad. She got a sense of dignity from
Biden leaving Afghanistan. It's out of this world.
Guys, it's completely and totally meaningless.
But notably, four allies in 12 seconds in that
earlier clip. That's one lie. Every three three
seconds that actually I would have. If you said,
David, you have 12 seconds to tell four lies. You
need real linguistic efficiency to even make that
happen. And Trump does it without even thinking
about it. We'll have these clips on our Instagram.
Find them at David Pakman show. We'll
take a quick break and be right back.